à quelqu'un qui sait.
Cela nous demande de sortir de notre zone de confort
et de prendre des risques.
Le problème est qu'en vieillissant,
on le fait plus rarement.
Nous enfermons qui nous sommes
et nous ne nous étirons plus.
Alors, avec mes élèves,
je passe beaucoup de temps à les encourager
à quitter la zone de confort, à prendre des risques.
Comment fais-je cela ?
Je commence par leur faire remplir un « Risquomètre ».
C'est une chose amusante que nous avons créée dans le cours
où ils planifient quels risques ils sont prêts à prendre.
Et cela leur devient très vite clair
que prendre des risques n'est pas binaire.
Il y a des risques intellectuels, physiques, financiers,
émotionnels, sociaux, éthiques et politiques.
Et quand ils voient cela, ils comparent leur profil avec les autres
et réalisent vite qu'ils sont tous différents.
Je les encourage ensuite à s'étirer,
à prendre des risques pour sortir de leur zone de confort.
Par exemple, je peux leur demander de prendre un risque intellectuel
en s'attaquant à un problème qu'ils n'ont jamais essayé ;
ou un risque social, parler à quelqu'un assis à côté d'eux dans le train ;
ou un risque émotionnel,
peut-être dire à quelqu'un de cher comment ils se sentent.
Je fais cela moi-même, tout le temps.
Il y a environ dix ans, j'étais dans un avion,
un vol très tôt dans la matinée en direction de l'Équateur.
Normalement, je mets juste mes écouteurs
je me couche, je me réveille, je travaille,
mais j'ai pris un petit risque,
en commençant une conversation avec l'homme à côté de moi.
Je me suis présentée, j'ai appris qu'il était éditeur.
Intéressant.
On a fini par avoir une conversation fascinante.
J'ai tout appris sur le futur de l'industrie éditoriale.
Ainsi, environ aux trois-quarts du vol,
j'ai voulu prendre un autre risque,
j'ai ouvert mon ordinateur et j'ai partagé une proposition de livre
que j'avais préparée pour faire quelque chose dans mes cours.
Comme il était très poli, il l'a lue,
et a dit : « Vous savez, Tina, cela ne nous correspond pas,
mais merci de l'avoir partagé. »
Ce n'est pas grave. Ce risque n'a pas marché.
J'ai fermé mon ordinateur.
A la fin du vol, nous avons échangé nos contacts.
Quelques mois plus tard, je l'ai contacté,
et j'ai dit : « Mark, aimeriez-vous venir à mon cours ?
Je fais un projet au sujet de réinventer le livre,
le futur de l'édition. »
Il a dit : « Super ! J'aimerais venir. »
Il est venu. Ce fut une super expérience.
Quelques mois après, je lui ai encore écrit.
Cette fois, je lui ai envoyé quelques clips vidéo
d'un projet que mes étudiants avaient fait.
Il était si intrigué
par un des projets des étudiants,
qu'il pensait que ça pourrait devenir un livre,
et il voulait rencontrer ces étudiants.
Je dois vous dire, j'étais un peu blessée.
(Rires)
Il voulait faire un livre avec mes étudiants, et pas avec moi,
mais OK, tout va bien.
Donc je l'ai invité, il est venu avec ses collègues à Stanford
et il a rencontré les étudiants, puis après, on a déjeuné ensemble.
Un de ses éditeurs m'a dit :
« Au fait, avez-vous déjà pensé à écrire un livre ? »
J'ai dit : « Vous allez rire. »
J'ai sorti exactement la même proposition
que j'avais montrée à son chef un an plus tôt.
En deux semaines, j'ai eu un contrat,
et en deux ans, le livre a été vendu à plus d'un million d'exemplaires.
(Applaudissements)
Alors, vous pourriez dire :
« Oh, vous êtes chanceuse. »
Oui, j'ai été chanceuse,
mais cette chance a résulté de la série de petits risques que j'ai pris,
en commençant par dire bonjour.
Et tout le monde peut faire ceci,
où que vous soyez dans votre vie,
où que vous soyez dans le monde,
même si vous pensez que vous êtes la personne la plus malchanceuse,
vous pouvez réussir en prenant de petits risques,
en sortant de votre zone de confort.
Vous construisez une voile pour saisir la chance.
La deuxième chose à faire
est de changer votre relation avec les autres.
Vous devez comprendre que tous ceux qui vous aident durant votre voyage
jouent un rôle énorme pour que vous atteigniez vos objectifs.
Si vous ne montrez pas de reconnaissance,
non seulement vous ne fermez pas la boucle
mais vous ratez une opportunité.
Quand quelqu'un fait une chose pour vous,
il prend ce temps
qu'il pourrait passer pour lui-même ou pour quelqu'un d'autre,
et vous devez reconnaître ce qu'il fait.
Je dirige trois programmes associatifs à Stanford,
et y entrer est très difficile,
et quand j'envoie les lettres aux étudiants qui ne rentrent pas,
je sais toujours qu'il y aura des personnes déçues.
Quelques-unes des personnes déçues m'envoient des mots, plaintifs.
Quelques-uns m'envoient des mots
demandant ce qu'il faut faire pour mieux réussir la prochaine fois.
Et de temps à autre,
quelqu'un m'envoie un mot pour me remercier de l'opportunité.
C'est arrivé il y a environ sept ans.
Un jeune homme, nommé Brian, m'a envoyé un joli mot disant :
« Je sais que j'ai été refusé dans ce programme deux fois,
mais je vous remercie pour l'opportunité.
J'ai beaucoup appris durant le processus de candidature. »
J'ai été tellement séduite par l'élégance de son message
que je l'ai invité à venir me rencontrer.
Nous avons passé du temps à parler et à préparer une idée
pour une étude indépendante, ensemble.
Il était dans l'équipe de football,
et a décidé de mener un projet sur le leadership dans ce contexte.
On a appris à bien se connaître pendant le trimestre
puis il a pris le projet qu'il avait commencé
dans l'étude indépendante
et l'a changé, finalement, en une société nommée « Play for Tomorrow »
où il enseigne à des enfants issus de milieux défavorisés
comment fabriquer la vie dont ils rêvent.
Alors, la chose importante au sujet de cette histoire
est que nous avons chacun fini par saisir les vents de la chance
en raison de son mot de remerciement.
Mais c'étaient les vents auxquels nous ne nous attendions pas au début.
Durant ces dernières années,
j'ai trouvé quelques tactiques pour ma propre vie
afin de mieux entretenir la reconnaissance.
Ma favorite est qu'à la fin de chaque journée,
je regarde mon calendrier et je regarde toutes les personnes que j'ai vues,
et j'envoie des mots de remerciement à chacune de celles-ci.
Cela prend uniquement quelques minutes,
mais à la fin de chaque journée,
je me sens incroyablement reconnaissante
et je vous promets que cela a augmenté ma chance.
Donc de une, il faut prendre des risques et sortir de sa zone de confort.
De deux, il faut montrer de la reconnaissance.
Et trois, il faut changer votre relation avec les idées.
La plupart des gens regardent les nouvelles idées et les jugent.
« C'est une bonne idée ! » ou « C'est une mauvaise idée. »
Mais c'est en fait bien plus nuancé.
Une idée n'est ni bonne ni mauvaise.
En fait, les graines des mauvaises idées sont souvent remarquables.
Un de mes exercices préférés dans mes cours sur la créativité
est d'aider les étudiants à regarder les mauvaises idées
à travers la lentille des possibilités.
Je leur donne un défi :
créer l'idée d'un nouveau restaurant.
Ils doivent trouver les meilleures idées pour celui-ci
et les pires idées pour un nouveau restaurant.
Les meilleures idées sont des choses comme un restaurant sur un sommet
avec un beau coucher de soleil,
ou un restaurant sur un bateau avec une vue magnifique.
Et les mauvaises idées sont un restaurant dans une décharge,
un restaurant très sale avec un service épouvantable
ou un restaurant qui sert des sushis aux cafards.
(Rires)
Ils me donnent donc toutes leurs idées,
je lis les bonnes à voix haute,
et ensuite je les déchire et les jette.
Je prends les idées horribles et je les redistribue.
Chaque équipe a donc une idée qu'une autre équipe pensait être terrible,
et le défi est de la changer en quelque chose de brillant.
Voilà ce qui se passe.
En 10 secondes, quelqu'un dit : « C'est une idée fabuleuse ! »
Et ils ont environ trois minutes avant d'annoncer leur idée à la classe.
Le restaurant dans la décharge ? Que devient-il ?
Ils collectent toute la nourriture en trop des restaurants étoilés
qui allait être jetée,
et ils ont un restaurant bien moins cher,
avec tous les restes.
Plutôt cool !
Ou le restaurant sale avec un mauvais service ?
Cela devient un restaurant qui sert de lieu d'entraînement
pour les futurs restaurateurs pour trouver comment éviter les embûches.
Et celui avec les sushis aux cafards ?
Il devient un bar à sushis
avec toutes sortes d'ingrédients intéressants et exotiques.
Si vous observez les entreprises,
les jeunes sociétés très innovantes autour de vous,
celles que l'on considère comme acquises et qui ont changé notre vie,
eh bien, vous savez quoi ?
Elles ont toutes commencé par des idées folles.
Ils ont lancé des idées, et quand ils les pitchaient,
la plupart des gens disaient : « C'est fou, ça ne marchera jamais. »
Donc, oui, parfois les gens naissent dans des conditions difficiles,
et parfois, la chance est un coup de foudre
qui nous frappe avec une chose merveilleuse ou terrifiante.
Mais les vents de la chance sont toujours là,
et si vous êtes prêt à prendre quelques risques,
si vous êtes prêt à sortir et montrer votre reconnaissance
et prêt à étudier les idées, même si elles sont folles,
à travers le prisme des possibilités,
vous pouvez créer une voile bien plus grande et saisir les vents de la chance.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)